Hello world it Saroj and Alphago zero
is deep minds popular AI that beat the
world champion at the game of go in a
match that was watched around the world.
In this video,
I'll explain how it works
using code and animations.
If you're new here,
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
to stay up to date on my latest AI
content.
Deep mind shocked the world in 2016 when
the initial version of Alphago beat 17
time world champion Lisa Dole.
Just a year later,
Alphago Zero unimproved virgin
that unlike its predecessor,
was trained without any
data from real human gangs.
It learned only by playing against
itself beat the world champion.
In regard to Alphago,
Ian Goodfellow,
our researcher at Google brain noted
that we're starting to see AI move beyond
what humans can tell the computer to do
and the AI can actually figure out how
to do something better
than the best human.
The idea that AI can think in ways we
can't was exemplified when Alpha go played
move 37 against Lisa Dole.
It was a seemingly bad
move to the human master,
but it turned out to be
crucial to its success.
It had learned a way of playing that
surpassed the 2000 years worth of
strategies humans had come up with,
but that should not seem scary.
The dot product operations
became self aware.
If we can combine this alien way of
thinking with our own to solve problems,
there's nothing we can't do.
The possibilities really are endless.
Whether it involves
discovery or creativity,
we just need to make sure everybody
understands how this power works.
A traditional game of go starts off
with an empty board and let's be real,
probably some tea.
Both players have an unlimited
supply of pieces called stones.
One taking the Blackstones and
the other takes the white stones.
The goal of the game is to use your
stones to form territories by surrounding
vacant areas of the board.
It's also possible to capture your
opponents stones by completely surrounding
them.
Both players take turns placing one of
their stones on an empty point at each
turn with black starting off.
These stones are placed on
the intersections of the
lines and one's played.
Stones cannot be moved, but they
can be captured when the game ends.
Both players count one point for each.
They can point inside of their own
territory and one point for each stone
they've captured the player
with the larger total
territory plus captured stones
is declared the winner with so many
possible positions to play here.
There are endless tactics to learn to
try and master this millennia old game.
So when thinking about
developing an algorithm for Bo,
we need to start listing the properties
of this game in a fundamental
mathematical way.
We know that go is a
discreet deterministic game
with perfect information.
Meaning there are individually separate
and distinct moves and positions.
Every move has a set outcome.
There are two players competing against
one another and both players are able to
see everything.
The whole position of the board.
It turns out that tic TAC toe is another
game that has those same properties.
Life isn't though,
unless you're Neil.
If you were to develop an
AI to beat tic tac toe,
then we could write a script that would
pick a move that results in the lowest
score for the opponent.
We know that there are three possible
values for a given game state.
Either it's a loss,
a win or a draw,
so our script would try out every possible
game states in real time forming a
tree of states.
Then perform a depth first search
to find the optimal move to play.
When we run our script,
we'll find that it will always either
win or draw with any human it plays
against, but could we apply this
same tree search to go well?
It turns out that there are more possible
go positions than there are atoms in
the universe.
So since go is such a complex game with
so many possible moves to play using a
brut force search to find the
best one simply isn't possible.
Using current computing hardware,
we need a strategy to initially explore
several possible moves on the board.
Then focus this exploration over time
as certain moves are found to be more
likely to lead to wins than others.
When our depth first search
method estimated the value
of a given state in the
search,
both players must play optimally choosing
the move that gives them the best
value and this required
computationally expensive recursion,
but instead of making the
players choose optimal moves,
what if we computed the value of a state
by making the players choose random
moves from there on and seeing who wins?
This is the basic idea behind
the Monte Carlo tree search,
the Goto Algorithm for writing bots to
play discreet deterministic games with
perfect information.
It uses random exploration to
estimate the value of a game state.
A single random game can be
called a layout and if we
play thousand layouts from
a given position,
x and player a wins
more than half the time,
it's likely that the position x is
better for player a than for player B.
We can create a Monte Carlo value function
that estimates the value of a state
using a given number of random play out.
The code will be similar to
the depth first search code,
but the difference is that instead of
iterating through all move possibilities
and picking the best one,
we randomly choose moves.
But random doesn't sound too intelligent,
does it?
What if we could have our algorithm
choose a move using some knowledge of what
moves are worth playing,
but not by trying them all out,
which would be very
expensive computationally,
but instead by computing a heuristic
approximation of the true value of each
move and choosing moves within play outs.
Based on this heuristic,
the UCT or upper confidence
tree score can help with this.
It's made for balancing both game
exploration and exploitation in a sensible
way.
I computing a heuristic value of a move.
The the is computed using the aggregated
score after playing a move in all
simulations thus far.
The number of plays of that move,
the number of games states
and an adjustable constant
representing the amount of
exploration to allow this equation helps
balance exploitation by playing known
moves with high values and exploration.
Trying how moves that have a low visit
count and updating the algorithm with
this new found knowledge
of how valuable they are.
Notice that UCT involves
learning over time,
whereas both DFS and plain MCTs or static
at first UCT is exploring lots of game
states,
but as it collects more data,
the random play outs become
less random and more heavy,
meaning it explores move paths that
have already proven to be good choices,
ignoring the rest.
This creates a self reinforcing cycle,
becoming more skewed towards
good moves than bad moves.
But check this out.
Sometimes two game states can have
pieces in different positions,
but the essential components of
the situation or the same meetings
strategically,
the difference in peace locations
might not matter to the UCT score.
These are two distinct game states,
but to humans,
we could intuitively know to that
similar strategies would apply to both.
It's essentially the same game state.
Rather than having AI memorize a surestep
value for every game state it finds
and storing it in a hash table.
What if it could learn heuristic
values from images of the game board?
Alphago zero sprinkled in a convolutional
neural network to do just that.
It used a massive 20 layer
residual network for this.
This is a convolutional network that
avoids the vanishing gradient problem
common in neural networks,
which makes them unable to learn longterm
sequences by creating a shortcut at
each layer,
which allows the gradient to skip over
intermediate layers and reach the bottom
during backpropagation
without being diminished.
While neural nets usually
output a single fixed output,
their network had two heads.
One took the output of the first 20 layers
and produced probabilities of the go
agent making certain moves and the other
took the output of the first 20 layers
and output a probability of
the current player winning.
So the training process of Alphago zero
for playing against itself in Games of
digital go started off with
initializing the residual network.
It used 1600 Monte Carlo tree search
simulations per move that it played and
sampled about 2000 positions from
the most recent 500,000 games.
Along with whether that game
was won or lost for every move.
It recorded the results of the
MCTs evaluation of those positions,
meaning how good the different
moves in these positions were.
Ace on looking ahead and whether the
current player won or lost the game.
The neural network was trained using
both the move evaluations produced by the
MCTs search and whether the current player
won or lost at every 1000 iterations
of this process.
The algorithm evaluated the current
residual network against the previous best
version.
If it won the majority of the Games,
it would begin using it to generate
self play games instead of the previous
version and that's really it.
It just use simulations to generate
training data for its neural nets.
Then learned from them in
a supervised way. In total,
it took Google 40 days to train Alphago
zero to become the best go player in the
world using 64 GPU and 19 CPS,
which costs millions of dollars.
While the hardware is expensive right now,
those costs are dropping.
And the idea of Alphago,
an AI that's able to master such a
complex game better than any human can by
playing against itself with no
human knowledge input is dope.
Aif Hey, you made it to the
end. You beautiful ways,
or you hit subscribe and connect
with me on Twitter, Instagram,
and Facebook for more developer education.
For now, I've got to search a tree,
so thanks for watching.